un oléoduc de 2000 km en pleine
construction une infrastructure monstre
pour exporter leur noir du Niger c'est
que les États africains éclament leur
droit au développement juste et
équitable et pour se faire il mise sur
leurs énergies fossiles ce projet a une
importance capitale pour notre pays
comme les pays développés ont eu la
chance de le faire
une contradiction totale avec le
discours ambiant dans les corridors de
la cop22
à la conférence cette écologiste
nigérienne est en mission convaincre les
pays développés de payer leur juste part
au pays en développement pour qu'ils
puissent envisager eux aussi une
transition verte sans quoi il craint que
le secteur pétrolier n'explose sur son
continent on n'est pas sorti du sur le
développement et pour assortir on ne
peut pas faire du développement c'est
l'énergie et cette énergie aujourd'hui
pour nous c'est le pétrole
pour déployer des énergies vertes il
faut technologie et moyens financiers
deux choses que les pays en
développement ont très peu faute de
transfert financier adéquat des plus
grands pollueurs du monde que faire
est-ce que le misère va croiser les bras
pour regarder sa population périple pour
regarder ces animaux périls pour
regarder son environnement dégradé
alternative togolais
est-ce que les pays du Sud ont également
le droit de pouvoir se développer en
utilisant en exploitant intelligemment
rationnellement les ressources et que
vous avez 646 millions d'Africains qui
cuisent encore aujourd'hui avec du bois
de feu dans mon pays le Togo la cuisine
mal faite tu sais mille personnes par an
c'est beaucoup plus que le sida et le
paluenau réunis
envers l'exploitation des ressources
pétrolières il met même en garde contre
les possibles dérapages
à cette clope on a vu l'Union européenne
presque signée et contrat avec l'Égypte
sur le gaz et ça continue à aller vers
le Sénégal etc on voit quand même qu'il
y a un appétit sur les pour les
ressources naturelles africaines est-ce
qu'on va bâtir la transition énergétique
dans le Nord sur les ressources du Sud